they met that mercy
with betrayal now they will feel my
wrath with the dark below we introduced
eris morn the character that introduces
you to all the story content and is
basically your narrator throughout so as
players we at bungie when we were taking
a look at that we thought there was a
lot to love about Eris and about the way
that we presented story through her so
what we wanted to do a house of wolves
was evolved that was to take the next
step so we introduced a brand new social
space the reef which includes not just
one character but a set of new
characters so we have pet revenge who is
the Queen's Guard and verax who is a
fallen who is still loyal to the Queen
and there's also brother Vance who
serves Osiris and and is the vendor for
the trials of Osiris so the characters
actually help flesh out the story quite
a bit we've got Petra telling the story
of the awoken we've got barracks telling
the story of the fallen and as you go
through the story through the story
content they they talk back and forth so
it provides a really interesting way to
flesh out the universe you've got
barracks who can actually speak fallen
so when you encounter enemies or bosses
and their chattering at you he'll
actually translate for you
telex has called you out guardian you
are challenged in the way is 0 and then
we have Petra who's talking about the
reef and about the Queen's agenda and
about how she fits into that and then
sort of as they banter back and forth
you really get a sense of the larger
world news story content is spread
across all the destinations and includes
a whole bunch of new space that we
haven't seen before with some amazing
arts and cool gameplay twists we'll also
go to some spaces that story content
players are not familiar with that allow
us to do some sort of unique gameplay
elements that story players haven't seen
before with the prison of elders we
wanted to make sure that we made an
activity type that was accessible to the
broadest array of players as possible so
there's a match made version at level 28
which is randomized so the match made
version as you play sort of start in the
central air lock and their doors four
doors that are all around you and they
open one after another in as you go into
each one of them you get into a combat
arena that focuses on one type of
combatant effects fallen ball and hive
then as you progress through you take
out all of the enemies and and and do
the gameplay with in one of those
quadrants you then progress on to the
next and the next and the next and it
gets more challenging as you go we also
throw in these things we call critical
objectives which throw a little twist
into the gameplay you might have to
defend an area or capture a point
there's there's a VIP that can spawn
that you have to take out and if you
fail at any of these objectives you wipe
and have to restart the round so you
know you're progressing through and you
don't know each time you play exactly
which combination of elements
going to get there also a set of
modifiers in there which changed the
gameplay dynamics it might change the
way your shield recharges or buff your
mailing attack and again all that's
randomized every time you play and then
and once you finish the first four
rounds you get boss round where one of
the quadrants opens and you get to fight
a unique boss so that's the matchmakers
the non match made version is at a
higher level of difficulty and rather
than being randomized we specifically
curate which which each round is going
to be in terms of the combatants in
terms of modifiers in terms of the
critical objectives and then at the end
you get a unique boss just for that
challenge which has its own custom-made
mechanics that you sort of have to
puzzle out and figure out how to take
the boss down you know we're always
developing new types of activities with
with house of wolves as we introduce the
the prison it's going to be very
interesting to see how players react to
it certainly we're always listening to
community feedback and any piece of
content any type of activity that
players absolutely love we're going to
want to make more of it
they are dead you
retweet